like missing yeah yeah they're looking
for holding water general water seal
look like what you got more of this
these are like right outside the door
that's my only back dude what exactly we
do with them no one really knows let's
see how long the interns can hold their
breath and sketch we're gonna shoot this
last Friday but then we have a surprise
trip to do I we get back and while still
jet-lagged had the plan and shoot this
whole video Tuesday okay so I'll have
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday to do effects this shot here the
car shot I think I'm gonna try to do
this one today because it's probably the
easiest shot in little pieces
this brick thing I think might have been
more than I bargained for it's frozen
because to make everything to real life
scale which I want to do it requires a
massive number of bricks this is a choke
point I didn't expect maybe it won't
work hey this is dumb and I should just
abandon it I guess I should learn my
name is Ray Fire got the issue on Friday
attention Saturday tea borders has a big
guy carrying machine gun known as the
heavy aah sounds like Harley to me
that's why it's a nerf team whole dress
and not just team fortress I know Jake a
challenge into a duel we just need to
get an equal in costume get him in
hos always like yeah perfect all right
tilt your head a little bit more like
this the quietest scream that no one
could ever hear you can feel it here
don't film ourselves low low smoothing
yeah math math math laughs at a
half-decent mesh
alright that's that's totally sufficient
anything above the wrists is legal John
here like in an hour
model of this chair that I'm sitting in
same in some Lego destruction over here
unfortunately some bits are bouncing and
doing weird things that don't actually
happen in real life you don't need the
texture just just do that then when we
have our Lego topple over and scatter
about I need to put some indicators as
to where the wall floor pewter Tower and
the desk are so that when they interact
with any part of the scene they'll
actually interact rendered out the host
up shot of Nikko rendered this out
slightly wider so I can crop in but just
an image so there are situations where
you don't need an actual video file
because the camera angle doesn't change
at all so there's no reason to really
make a big sequence and no one will ever
notice
no one's gonna be like ah actually the
timing on that first transformation
wouldn't have completed by this start of
that second shot now because I said that
people gonna say that have a headache
we're gonna go get some lunch but while
we're at lunch I'm gonna let this render
really quick I'm gonna render out the
shadow pass random for two marks in the
wall doing the tedious task of clumping
multiple Lego bricks together trying to
make it so that when Nikko bursts into a
couple pieces or Lego bricks it doesn't
just turn into every individual brick
because yeah if you were to break it
like a model it wouldn't just perfectly
split like that
oh hey OB no okay huh
dogs oh yeah now you want to come back
making some pretty good progress
actually this is a windshield the video
goes out tomorrow and we're here all the
way not just me Carmichael here to do it
sound as I'm editing this what I'm doing
now I think will work I had to take the
car and I've split into at least 22
different pieces now and I'm taking
those pieces into Parker and turning it
into bricks but sometimes it still is
too many bricks in the windows windows
obviously it's too thin I'll just make
the windshield thicker the wind the
windows thicker actually get some volume
to the windows even though else like you
has windshields this thick but I made
the model that thick so that I can
actually make some Legos out of it and
again the same thing not angry little
frustrated I'm not overworked for the
record this was supposed to be the
easiest shot in the entire video it was
just a car we didn't even have it like a
3d camera move so for the render I'm
literally just gonna render out a still
frame and track it into the shot nothing
advanced about that all this were shot
that we might as well just cut but
here's the thing we don't have enough
segments for the video for the shot to
just be cut it works see look at that
individual bricks they're all different
I can move on from the shot now
hi I'm done anyways since lego - video
is almost done we're all going to chip
in a couple hours each right now sit
down we work on color grading this thing
while Sam and I are out shooting the
movie the guys picked up the program
film convert which lets you basically on
a program that takes different camera
profiles based on what you shot and
matches it to a film looks we've got to
release videos on Monday every two weeks
forever
so Carmichael had this great idea since
we have this bucket of Legos let's
actually just pour the Legos out to kind
of use those sound files in addition to
the sweet ice and rock pack that you got
but that means pour them everywhere in
Legos like that they are not the easiest
things to collect color grades done
don't convert school mixing a workflow
of putting a new metric color on first
and like tweaking your exposure or
blacks and whites and that kind of stuff
and come convert on tops and adjustment
layer kind of doing an overall grade
work pretty well it's pretty fast
because it's like perfect just like here
we are in reality but we're filming with
a nice camera versus like here we are
and the colors of this will represent
the colors my soul and our
nice my shirt okay you guys like these
you can get them on the quarter website
they're nice and fuzzy inside
it is now 10:30 p.m.
we finally have basically the whole
video done goes up and seven hours is it
going up if fibers going up a seven you
know see they're gonna go up at 5 a.m.
or 7 a.m. which means to see they're
gonna go up in 6 and 1/2 hours or eight
and a half hours if you want to see more
follow the quarter digital Instagram and
Twitter castle if you want to talk to me
more follow me on Ren the Reaper at
Twitter I said that backwards what am I
here to do watch internet videos and
kick butt I'm all out of butt
hey how are you are you filming yeah
are you guys this I do you say